let's say we have a linear equation and
we know when x is equal to 4
that that y is equal to 9 and we've
plotted that point here on our xy plane
actually i forgot to label the x the
x-axis right over there and let's say we
also know we also know that when x is
equal to 6
y is equal to 1 and we've plotted that
point there and so this green line
represents all of the solutions to this
linear equation
now what i want to do in this video is i
want to say well can we find that linear
equation and can we express it in both
point slope form and in slope intercept
form and i encourage you like always
pause the video and see if you can do it
so let's first think about point slope
form
point
slope
point slope form and point slope form is
very easy to generate if you know a
point on the line or if you know a point
that satisfies where the x and y
coordinates satisfy the linear equation
and if you were to know the slope of the
of the line that represents the solution
set of that linear equation
now for sure we actually were given two
points that are solutions that represent
solutions to the linear equation
to fully apply point slope or to apply
point slope easily we just have to
figure out the slope and what we could
do is we could just evaluate what's the
slope between the two points that we
know and we just have to remind
ourselves that slope
slope is equal to
slope
is equal to change in y over change in x
sometimes people say rise over run
and what's that going to be
well if we say if we if we say that this
this second point right over here
if we say if we say this is kind of our
if we're starting at this point and we
go to that point then our change in y
going from this point to that point is
going to be it's going to be equal to
minus
minus 9
minus 9. this point right over here is
the point
comma 1. so we started at y equals 9 we
finish at y equals 1. our change in y is
going to be 1 minus 9. we have a
negative 8 change in y which makes sense
we've gone down 8.
so this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to negative 8
that's our change in y and what's our
change in x well we go from x equals 4
to x equals six
so we end up at x equals six and we
started at x equals four
we started at x equals four so our
change in x is six minus four which is
equal to two
which is equal to 2. and you could have
even done it visually to go from this
point to this point your change in y
your change in y
is you went down 8. so your change in
let me write this
so your change in y is equal to negative
eight
and what was your change in x to get and
get to this point
well your change in x is positive two
so your change in x is equal to
two and so what's your slope change in y
over change in x negative 8 over 2 is
equal to
negative 4.
so now that we have a now that we know
the slope and we know a point and we
know a and we know a point we actually
know two points on the line we can
express this in point-slope form
and so let's do that
and the way i like to do is i always
like to just take it straight from the
definition of what slope is
we know that the slope between any two
points on this line is going to be
negative 4. so if we take an arbitrary y
that sits on this line
and if we find the difference between
that y and let's focus on this point up
here
so if we find the difference in that y
and this y and
nine and it's over
over the difference between some x on
the line and this x
and 4
and 4.
this is going to be the slope between
any x y on this line and this point
right over here and the slope between
any two points on a line are going to
have to be constant so this is going to
be equal to the slope of the line it's
going to be equal to negative 4.
and we're not in point-slope form or
classic point-slope form just yet to do
that we just multiply both sides times x
minus 4.
so we get
y minus 9
we get y minus 9 is equal to
our slope negative 4
times x minus 4
times x minus 4. and this right over
here is our classic this right over here
is our classic point slope form we have
the point sometimes they even put
parentheses like this but we could
figure out the point from this
point-slope form the point that sits on
this line would be things that make both
sides of this equation equal to 0. so it
would be x equals 4 y equals 9 which we
have right up there and then the slope
is right over here it's negative 4.
now from this can we now express this
this this linear equation in y-intercept
form
in y-intercept form just as a bit of a
reminder it's y is equal to mx
plus b
where this coefficient is our slope and
this constant right over here is allows
us to figure out our y-intercept and to
get this and to get this in this form we
just have to simplify a little bit of
this algebra
so you have y minus 9
y minus 9 is equal to well let's
distribute this negative 4 and i'll just
switch some colors let's distribute this
negative 4 negative 4 times x is
negative 4x
negative 4 times negative 4 is plus 16.
and now if we just want to isolate the y
on the left-hand side we can add 9 to
both sides so let's do that let's add 9.
let's add 9 to both sides
let's add 9 to both sides on the left
hand side we're just left with y and on
the right hand side we're left with
negative 4 x and then 16 plus 9 is plus
25 and there you have it we have the
same linear equation but it's now
represented in slope-intercept form once
again we see the slope right over here
and now we can figure out what the
y-intercept is the y-intercept when x is
equal to 0 y is going to be equal to 25.
my axis right here i haven't drawn it
high enough but if i if i made it even
taller and taller and you see that's the
this line is going to intersect the
y-axis when y is equal to
y is equal to 25. so there you go we
wrote it in point-slope form
that is that right over there and we
wrote it in y
sorry we wrote it in slope
we wrote it in slope-intercept form
point slope and slope intercept
hopefully you enjoy that